[Music]
I'm just hoping that I can you know make
everybody proud Tonya Harding made her
debut on Mondays premiere of Dancing
with the Stars athletes although she was
tearful in her opening package don't
fail again Tonya's Foxtrot with partner
Sasha Farber was well received by judges
sure
[Music]
in the audience to support the stars of
I Tanya allison janney alongside Tanya
Pendergrass Oviedo major Oscar winner
Allison Janney is in the ballroom to
support you what do you make of that
well I asked Allison and Stephen to come
and the little young lady who played me
in the movie as well and I was just so
thankful that they were here because
without them I probably wouldn't be here
and thank everybody for voting for us I
mean it's amazing we're going to the
second round saying that you deserve
this chance for people to see you who
you really are do you think that Dancing
with the Stars has opened the up that
world all of this after being on the
ballroom floor tonight well I think it's
definitely a start people will get to
see me for something new something that
they haven't seen before or heard before
I know you can't make everyone proud but
I know I'm making myself proud and as
long as Sasha has a smile on his face
then you know he's a wonderful partner
Tania and Sasha how are you feeling when
you were up there it's very scary but
it's scary for all of us I mean we're
all here just trying to make a
difference in our lives and we're so
excited to be here and be part of
something wonderful but it was like the
scariest moment I think I've been in in
a really long time oh my god so you meet
Emma listen we're married we love each
other I'm sad for her and life goes on
but I'm you know what I'm so I'm so
proud of Tania and what she's achieved
tonight literally because she has had
everything taken away from her and it's
not fair and I think tonight she has
proven herself that this is a second
chance and what better way to do it huh
then Dancing with the Stars
[Music]
[Applause]